dans son petit atelier à buc jean-claude
l'ouvrier ex champion de bmx nous
dévoile le portrait sur lequel il a
travaillé pendant plusieurs semaines
manon valentino elle-même championne de
bmx qui a participé aux jeux olympiques
de rio l'année dernière pourquoi ma non
parce que parce que maintenant parce que
maintenant elle avait une histoire assez
sympathique parce que l'avait pris
elle avait fait une grosse chute s'était
cassé la suite visiblement ce n'était
pas sûr qu'elle a les jeux olympiques et
puis et puis bah non parce que comme ça
on me l'a proposé puis je trouvais ça
sympa
l'artiste qui revient à ses premières
amours pour le bmx est exposée au grand
palais à paris et retrouve manon
valentino en personne qui le découvrent
pour la première fois quand je les vis
aux lois et j'étais non non je
m'attendais pas qu'aux grands et
forcément c'est ouais c'est beaucoup
d'émotion et puis je pense direct au
fait que je vous envoie une photo ma
maman elle va trouver ça encore quand je
les ai vus quoi voilà je pense que c'est
gagné quoi et puis je suis super heureux
quoi moi franchement annexe un ancien du
circuit mondial bmx rencontré une
nouvelle du circuit mondial bmx mais en
course assez franchement c'est super
regard de braise cheveux domptés une
féminité très présente sur son bmx avant
un départ imminent sur la piste très ému
par son portrait manon valentino
rappelle que son sport a une image
plutôt masculine c'est ce que j'aime
c'est ce que j'aime c'est je fais un
détour je fais un sport de mecs je dis
oui mais justement en dessous il ya une
guerrière est allé gaillard ce sont des
femmes
il y en a eu beaucoup dans le temps et
nous maintenant on est derrière avec
laurent à la fin de l'exposition
le tableau rejoindre à manom valentino à
bordeaux